To work with these storyboarding tools, we also need to understand how to work with cameras
inside of Unreal Engine.
So we have two different types of cameras.
We have the Cine Camera Actor, which is the most commonly used.
It's a camera that emulates real-life cameras, not unlike a game camera, but we have more
options such as the film back, lens, focus, and tracking options.
So if you're unsure what Cine Camera Actors are, plenty of documentation on these, and
it's definitely worth looking into all the different options that they have, you can
just find that from the Place Actors window in the Cinematics tab, and you're looking
for the Cine Camera Actor there.
We also have Scene Capture Component 2D, which is used to capture a snapshot of the scene
from a single plane and then feed that into a render target.
So if you're trying to render just a certain frame, this may be the option to go to there.
So with the Cine Cameras, we have these film back settings, which essentially sets the
aspect ratio.
So you can see the film back here with the sensor, width and height, and then it gives
you some form of aspect ratio based on the width and height values.
You've got your lens settings where you can set focal lengths and S-stops, focus settings
where you can track certain actors, whether it be a manual tracking or an actor tracking,
and then just a whole host of other properties.
So again, if you're unfamiliar with what Cine Camera Actors are, it's definitely worth
checking out the documentation.
Also just dragging and dropping a Cine Camera Actor into your scene, playing around with
the different properties can help you understand exactly what the different properties are
doing within your project.